Hillary Clinton have you heard about
this lady her husband was the former
governor of Arkansas he became president
then she became a senator from New York
then she became Secretary of State
natural dart choices and she was
interviewed by Diane Sawyer on ABC News
and had some interesting things to say
about the Clintons life post presidency
it has been reported you've made five
million making speeches the president
made more than a hundred million dollars
well if you you have no reason to
remember but we came out of the White
House not only dead broke but in debt we
had no money when we got there and we
struggled to you know piece together the
resources for mortgages for houses for
Chelsea's education you know it was not
easy they had no money when they got
there I didn't know that and then not
only dead broke but in debt when they
left max we were watching this before we
started and you picked up on an
interesting added s I mean she makes it
sound like her life was really hard
having multiple houses yeah yeah it was
plural I can't believe that they left
the why is is that true well actually
according to open secrets in 2000 when
the Clintons left the White House they
had a net worth of negative ten million
dollars but you could only get to a net
worth of negative ten million dollars if
you had access to tons of money before
that so for her to imply that somehow
they were dead broke or really in debt
knowing how much money was about to come
in 100 million bucks from Clinton there
are levels of insanely rich yeah okay
and we will probably never be in this
boat but I get where she's coming from
that's true it's all possible but no I
mean I mean I think yeah there's a
there's a little bit of disingenuous and
genuine is going on here but at the same
time yeah they had to pay a lot of legal
fees for all that whitewater crap and
all the other sort of [ __ ]
accusations that got hold of them over
the course of eight years they had a
daughter to put through school yes they
have multiple houses I'm not no one is
thinking that these people are you know
gonna go on food stamps or understand
the idea of genuine poverty but I
don't begrudge them the ability to make
money making speeches I mean you know
we'll get to that part I don't think
anyone begrudges them the chance to make
money by the way Bill Clinton as former
president gets you know a yearly salary
so the stipend of like 120,000 which is
still more than most people make on top
of all the money for speeches and all
that but that all right so let's talk
about then what happened after so then
Hillary chimed in with this first of all
we had to pay off all our debts which
was you know you had to make double the
money because of obviously taxes and
then pay off the debts and get us houses
and take care of family members but do
you think Americans gonna understand
five times the median income in this
country for one speech well let me put
it this way I thought making speeches
for money was a much better thing than
getting connected with any one group or
company as so many people who leave
public life do oh she's so much better
than everyone else in public life
because not there not only this she
doesn't take money from one giant
company she takes money pretty much from
everybody she's taken a lot of money
from goldman sachs defend her go how
many seconds before eric cantor becomes
a lobbyist all right robbing door is for
these people to go back and like shill
for you know big armaments or for farm
or whoever else so i you know i will at
least give her the point like yeah you
expect you you accept money for speeches
you or at least singing for your supper
it's a great supper obviously but you're
not in anybody's pocket you know with so
many former politicians are i look i'm
not a favorable think she's in any one
when she takes 500,000 for two speeches
to absolutely I'm not saying the
Clintons are pure and perfect or
anything else but I'm just saying I
think we're kind of hot piling on for a
relatively non gross way of being a
former politician
yeah I've seen Clinton speak on behalf
of global Clinton Global Initiative and
I you know I'm always you know
completely inspired by by him and the
work that they're doing and yeah I don't
begrudge them anything
yeah but this is to me this isn't about
progression because I agree with you
they have to make money somehow people
pay them for these speeches that's fine
I was you know we are a capitalistic
Society it's more the idea that she's
framing it
as if they struggled which it's so do
you think they've ever not been able to
get since he's been president or even
probably a little bit before that do you
think there's anything they've ever
wanted that they haven't been able to
get have they ever not been able to go
to a restaurant that they wanted to go
to or buy a car that they wanted or
anything so it's the struggle it's not
the right but maybe the question here is
why is Diane Sawyer framing it like oh
how dare you make this much money
go ask george w bush that question go
ask you know any former senator who is
now you know shilling from
northrup-grumman that question water
know why when hillary it's like when
hillary does it suddenly it's the worst
thing ever
well I totally hear that and listen I
would give Dick Cheney as much [ __ ] for
you know helping a Halliburton get
contracts would you end up back so I'm
just giving them all equal this isn't
necessarily all about their reminds me
of that line from The Dark Knight Rises
we're talking about superhero movies so
it rings it I mean they don't even go
broke like the rest of us could I ever
get in ten million dollars that that
would be virtually impossible this is
this is a one-percent style bankruptcy
yeah yeah which is somebody who's
willing to loan you ten million and
you're able to pay it back and then some
yeah a pretty good set of problems why
is it that people are so afraid of being
proud of success because I think that
that goes to what you're saying about
Diane Sawyer's question there's this
this idea that everyone has to be
struggling all the time people who are
running for president need to come off
as relatable and you know you know I
hear vague things I don't know but you
know I think she this is clearly part of
the narrative of you know just plain
folks which they have worked to a
certain extent or other ever since
leaving Arkansas yeah do we do you think
we have this like weird implicit shame
about success in this country um you
know if we do it's sad you know I like
to think that we should you know be
proud of people and hold people as
examples when they become successful for
noble causes you know and I think it's
important to see them as relatable but I
think that their their necessity for
that has passed you know that's what got
him into office yeah well yeah I mean I
you know again I think that that the
success that they've had post post
presidency I think is warranted yeah
alright well I think what we learned
here is
that I will not be voting for Hillary I
think Alonzo will be voting for Hillary
I will maybe I don't overdress who runs
against runner and max possibly I see a
possible I see a probable okay